hello and welcome to the oven Carmichael
show I believe when entrepreneurs and
this show is all about helping you
achieve your dreams your business goals
it's been a while since I've had the
program so it's austin to be back i'm
also excited to welcome my new producer
josh to the program it's our first show
together so Josh welcome aboard man now
you know I was a guy who was the
entrepreneur making 300 bucks a month
wanted to give up on my dream thinking
it was not possible telling my business
partner I quit and managed to break
through and build your decimal company
and get acquired and and start other
companies and build them up so I know I
know how hard it is and I know that
often you feel you're all alone in this
and you may feel stock in the Momentum's
not there and that's what this show is
all about it and I want to help you get
through those challenges that you're
facing with your business right now on
the agenda today I'm talking about the
doubters okay how to deal with the
doubters in your life I'm introducing a
new segment talking about the tools of
the week that I use for my business I'm
talking about how to get leverage out of
social media and a company that really
upset me this week and then I'm going to
close with doing something nice or
somebody and how that can help you with
your business let's talk about the
doubters ok we all have doubters in our
lives you have doubters you know that
the people in your life who tell you all
the reasons why you are not going to
make it why you should quit why you
should go do something now they tell
you've got a stupid idea I like to call
this group of people the little man okay
and here's the good news you're not
alone everybody had a little man in
their life Marilyn Monroe was let go
from her first movie contract because
the production sheet at the studio
thought she was unattractive Marilyn
Monroe unattractive dr. Seuss that the
children's author his first book was
rejected by 27 publishers before was
finally picked up by somebody 27
publishers
Elvis Presley he was fired by the Grand
Old Opry manager who told him Elvis you
ain't going nowhere son you ought to go
back to driving a truck are you kidding
me here's the thing that you have to
understand okay little man can often be
an expert if your aunt back or one of
your old high school buddies is telling
you that you should have banging your
dreams yeah that hurts okay it hurts it
sting do you want people to support you
but you can always chug it off and say
to yourself hey you know what they don't
know what they're talking about i'm
going to go do this for me but quite
often the little man is an expert in
your field he knows what he's talking
about he could have years of experience
and be a big player in the field what
you have to remember is that only you
can kill your dream if you have a dream
to do something then the only person who
can get in the way from that happening
is you what if Marilyn Monroe listen to
that production chief what if dr. suits
listen to those 27 publishers whatever
expressly listened to that Grand Ole
Opry manager keep be driving truck
dreaming of a life that could have been
it's hard you know the bigger your dream
the more people are going to tell you
that's not possible the more obstacles
you're going to have in your way the
more you're going to doubt yourself it's
hard but you have to keep going
otherwise you'll be driving truck
instead of living out your dream and
that's not because of the little man
that's not because of the doubters
that's on you it's your choice now I
have a little man in my life when i
launched my believe by video series an
expert in the video production business
said it was too long would never work
fast forward four months and that first
video now has over 400,000 views and is
growing every day now i'm going now i'm
writing a book and some top people in
the book industry they don't like my
idea but i'm going to make it happen
anyway it's my choice not there it's my
dream not theirs so if you have a dream
go make it happen take steps every
single day to do something to move
forward and don't let anybody hold you
back believe I have Michael on the line
where are you from and how can I know
hey Evan I'm from Shreveport Louisiana I
imma imma make it happen kind of person
and my question really segues with what
you just recently talked about um you
know I'm a go-getter I'm I've opened for
offices in my industry and I'm
constantly on the go on the go but just
recently I've been feeling just a little
bit like I need somebody to lift me up
you know i'm constantly lifting my
employees up i'm constantly motivating
my wife and my children that work with
me and you know where do i go to get a
little bit of something like you know
you can do this you've been to the great
job you know where'd I get a little left
uplift myself yeah it's lonely at the
time it is being a leader in being the
one that's always motivating everybody
every once in a while like right now you
kind of like me and I need a list yeah
do you have any entrepreneur friends
Michael their friends but they're
competitors mmm you know most of my
competitors are my friends and most of
my people I talked to with the most are
my competitors so it's so I can't really
let a weakness slip you know yeah yeah
you don't go to networking events for
conferences and say you know what I'm
really struggling yeah really no way
right good stuff you know this is really
common you know this is super common
with entrepreneurs and one of the things
that that I've done here in Toronto and
maybe you could do in Louisiana is I've
started a mastermind group and basically
what it is it's a group of entrepreneurs
between four and eight members and we
meet once a month just to help each
other out sometimes they like to call
entrepreneurs anonymous but it's just
you know give another perspective help
you realize that you're on track and and
help help each other out you know it's
it's hard being an entrepreneur so I
don't know if there's anything in
Louisiana right now that has been set up
for entrepreneurs there was nothing in
my hometown
so I made it myself but just being
around other entrepreneurs of knowing
that you know what I like to do a pretty
good job helps keep you I'm going crazy
sometimes yeah I mean you know my bank
account makes me happy and that is what
I'm used as a judge of I'm doing okay
but you know like I belong to the
Chamber of Commerce and I want when I'm
out there I'm always that over-the-top
friendly goddess got it all together
making it happen and so you know that I
like the Don Smith anonymous type saying
both doesn't that sound like it would
fit me just right you need a group of
people who you can feel comfortable
sharing your your biggest
vulnerabilities with mm-hmm so I've got
you know and it actually ends up
creating way better relationships
because they all have problems too right
i mean you go to these Chamber of
Commerce events and everybody's just
talking about the great things that are
happening but they all have their own
business challenges too and when you
understand that it's bonded it creates a
much stronger bond with the people
you're connecting with okay I know
you're not going to work with chamber
commerce and start you know tell
everybody all you know your life story
and how hard everything is but I would
try to identify a group of people you
could start with two or three people who
you can meet with once a month and it
can be supporting for mo just be over
dinner and we meet over dinner just to
have everybody go around and share
what's going on and try to help each
other out is there anybody that comes to
mind it might be a potential speak for
that we know I do have a business mentor
that is not financially involved with me
okay and I think he might be a good
start with something like that yeah
because I'm always telling him like I'm
normally always telling them my greatest
latest I marketing idea you know maybe I
could share a little bit with him like
man I hey it's been a tough month yeah I
mean that's the real value of a mentor
honestly now I just want to sharing the
great stuff you want how
what the stuff is really bothering you
so that's between art and I'd also try
to reach out and now that you're
thinking about it keep that open mind
and see if there's anybody else in your
network as you connect with people who
you get along really well with who might
be a fit to help to come out and join
the group and if you get a group of
people together again I usually looking
for as a minimum but that helps you if
your entrepreneur this man we all need
it we all need the boots and support to
keep going but you're doing a great job
and it can be lonely at the top all
right appreciate Evan no problem Michael
good luck and for everybody listening
everybody has problems okay you look at
other distances and you think well
everybody's doing so well and I feel so
down on myself but everybody has
problems everybody has thought about
quitting everybody has major major
challenges and surrounding yourself with
people who you can feel comfortable
enough to talk to ensure those
challenges with can make such a huge
boost in your motivation and keep them
you doing welcome back to the other
Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs I want to see you have mad
success with your company and I want you
to be productive a lot of entrepreneurs
are feelings are not productive than
running around and what I'm trying to do
now with a new segment on my show was
introduced a tool of the week so let me
know what you guys think afterwards my
tool of the week this week is Dropbox if
you haven't heard of dropbox go check it
out john fox com what it basically
allows you to do is share a folder with
other people on your team so if your
email in PowerPoint files Excel
spreadsheets back and forth the people
on your team it can get really messy and
you're not sure who's updated water you
got to see the files of different
folders what a love about dropbox is you
create a folder on your computer you
share it with somebody else and it
automatically downloads to their
computer so if you're sharing files with
somebody on your team if you make a
change if you put something in that
folder if you update an Excel
spreadsheet is automatically updates it
on their computers so it's a great way
to share files and I've done that with
everybody on my team I have a joint
dropbox folder with them I've also done
for personal reasons you know I have a
Dropbox with my parents and when they
take my son off to their leg cows going
to take pictures they pop them in the
dropbox i turn on my computer and all
the pictures are there automatically
it's amazing the other great benefit is
if you have multiple computers you may
have a desktop at the office and a
laptop at home you can put all your
files on dropbox and still sync
automatically so you want to email your
files boxing forwards at home and office
and homeland office you just load up
your computer if you've made a change at
the office it's automatically there when
you get home and vice versa the last big
thing about is it syncs your files
automatically on lines if you deleted
something you can go back and get it and
I put all of my files on dropbox so now
whenever I load a new computers i just
got a new computer two weeks ago all i
had to do was get my dropbox installed
leave it to run overnight and all my
files are automatically there for me the
next day so it's perfect check it out
it's free i'm not affiliated with the
company other than being a happy
customer you get two gigabytes of free
and then you can start to pay either
five or ten bucks a month for more space
afterwards so check it out dropbox com
that's my tool of the week I have
Danielle on the line Danya where are you
from how can I go hi I'm from New Jersey
welcome to the show what's going on well
I had recently came up with um and
invention that I've met with someone for
something that can possibly help save
people's lives mainly for children okay
with all the you see a lot on facebook
with a lot of kids are missing it's good
for if someone's missing if you're in a
home invasion robbery fire it's
basically what it is it's like a silent
alarm GPS tracking device that I met
with an advanced company that would
working on putting together right now
like you have with like I work with
elderly people and one of my clients you
know he has the Life Alert yeah where it
could contact
authority that there's a marked an
emergency and with mines is like where
it's not going to only contact the
parties it's going to send off the
signal to your family members as well
where it gives everyone time to react
that one okay requisite already litter
what is it that they're putting on well
I wanted I want to get it made into
different things but like for right now
it'll just be something with three
different buttons on it one for medical
fire or any kind of emergency like for
example if someone breaks into my home
and they're expecting you to have a
phone and a lot of times you don't have
time to be on the phone with 911
explaining things and with this if
you're taking out of your home or
kidnapped or something like that where
you can't talk where and someone takes
you somewhere you have to but it not
only is it going to contact the cops
it's going to contact your family
members and track your every move where
and so how can I help what question do
you have um well basically um what I
wanted to just I wanted to something
just get out there to people and let
people know about my invention and also
right now what I'm doing is my last step
I have a full report when it done from
the company and just looking for
investors right now okay do you have a
patent on this yes I had met with um the
event company they're out in
Pennsylvania okay and that's the last
step they're going to help they said
that they will help with as far as um
press release commercial and everything
else I mean the guy he loved the idea
and that was that's pretty much the last
step as far as I can you have a patent
on the on the product yeah he's not
everything was done yeah and you own
that or they're another company owns a
patent
no i came i went to the company so that
way they could help me and get it
together okay but the ownership of the
patent is you that would be me perfect
yeah so I mean it's going to be one of
the things that the inventor is its are
the investors are going to look at is
you know for any new technology do you
have the patent and I have been worth
investing yes I know that is some
because but the thing is it's like fine
happens every single day that's
something that's never going to stop and
with something like this if it can save
time with the police and family members
and everything else as far as tracking
someone in the case of an emergency like
this is something that will be to be
around what we're long gone and this is
something that you wear or it's uh yes
it can be something that you wear like I
wanted to I want to do it in ways where
it's things that we wear every day
whether it's a earring whether it is a
ring where the diamond on a ring it
looks like a diamond but it's actually a
a button where someone takes it
instilled it's tracking their every move
as well as it's concealed yes cool well
what's what's the name of your company
or have you set it up you got a website
well right now I have a friend of mine's
working on put the website together for
me because actually we just finished
everything I just got the report from
the events company and as far as that
next step is just like he said just had
to find investors and everything it in
that way he can get it out to the media
through the commercial for it and good
luck with the lunch thank you and maybe
you know back when it's up and you can
give us a website okay well it'll be
finished soon all right thanks and yo
think everybody listen here you got an
invention you're trying to raise money
for it make sure you have the
that's one of the first things that the
investors are going to look at if you
don't have the patent for your idea then
it's going to be super challenging to
get investors to put money in so go
check it out it does customized you can
go with a provisional patent to start
and then expand some that now I get
asked a lot by entrepreneurs the right
to me and they say hey Evan how do I
have success with social media they see
all the success I'm having with Twitter
and YouTube and Facebook and how do I
want some of that I need to get some
results from my social media campaign I
want to tell you a quick story about how
not to do it okay a company reached out
to me earlier this week called neo reach
what's a complete wrong approach so
these guys do is they say hey Evan we
want to partner with you and there are
some brands who want to work with you
and they want you to tweet out some
promotional information for them and
every time somebody clicks on that link
we're going to PU the challenge here is
to many people treat social media like
advertising if you were treating social
media like a pay-per-click ad word
campaign you're going to fail that's not
what social media is all about look at
your stuff okay look at what you're
sharing are you actually proud of what
you put up because if you're not then
you have to change your campaign around
social media what you want to think
about it is think about it as you're
actually meeting you right you're at a
party you're talking to friends this is
where word of mouth and referrals happen
it's not where advertising that's
supposed to happen and too many
entrepreneurs and big businesses do not
a lot of people getting this wrong too
many people are just broadcasting the
stuff you're sharing socks is boring its
promotional look at what you're sharing
look at what your company's putting out
there on social media if you weren't the
president of your business would you
retweet that would you share that with
your friends probably not and that's the
problem that's why you're not getting
any engagement
you don't need to be out there
advertising and social media campaigns
because they saw Craig now you've got to
do a better job in putting together
campaigns that mean something so it
starts with thinking about what are you
staying for as an entrepreneur what is
your business staying for what change
you're trying to make for the better in
this world and then you start sharing
stuff thats related to that I want you
to share something that makes people
think that stirs up some emotion then
they read that post they can't wait to
share it with their friends because
that's not going to happen from your
coupon codes and your marketing
promotion and your advertising as long
as you approach social media was an
advertising angle you're never going to
have success these companies are not
going to have success and it's only
going to get harder because more and
more and more people are coming online
more businesses are coming online and
open it up their social media accounts
so your competition is growing
exponentially but there's always room
for quality at the top so what do you do
again start with one thing that you
staying for right what are you staying
for what's the positive change you want
to make in the world and then start
sharing quotes that you like that
inspire me share videos that you've
watched and that you enjoy share
articles that you've read and that you
recommend even if none of these have
anything to do with your business and
what you're doing you're building a
community because if you want people to
buy from you they have to know you like
you trust you first that's what you're
sharing on social media and then maybe
twenty percent of the stuff you're
sharing is actually promotional but the
meat has to be value as stuff that when
you look at this is the asset text you
look at it you feel proud say I make
that and I'm proud of it when you get
there because social media campaign you
have a lot more success I want to get to
the calls I have Sasha on the phone
Sasha where are you from and how can I
help hey I'm Sasha i'm in orlando
florida
and i'm the author of the children's
book i wrote based on my children called
waiting for baby why that's leading the
number for baby in a letter Y because
all my children's names start with the
letter Y and basically yacht in yoel and
josiah cool okay yeah and it's basically
about when I was pregnant with my third
son and how the two big brothers can it
wait for the baby to be born and they
had a weight you know what nine long
months and it's a cute children book and
basically I just have had you know like
kind of difficulties trying to think of
creative ways to like market the book to
the target audiences which would be you
know young children expecting mothers on
parents you know basically and I'm just
you know like out of ideas on what to do
I don't have like a lot of time can I do
you know how three boys and they're very
young so I just wanted to know if you
had any creative ways that I could you
know try to market the book to a target
audience is there a teachable lesson in
the book like if I read this to my son
is there something he's going to learn
from it um yes basically that you know
all great things you have to wait for in
life you know like it's definitely worth
the wait the boys learn at the end of
the book that it was worth waiting the
nine long months because this miracle
you know their little brother was born
so it was worth the wait so that's
that's the lesson you know that some
things you have to wait for life okay
cool and is it something that could be
used as a tool for parents who are
expecting that the early have a child
and they're expecting another one they
could read this to their kids almost
definitely yes that's that's basically
what through the book is basically for
you know like the sibling but also helps
to keep them the older siblings helps to
keep them a part of you know a part of
what's going on because sometimes you
know they can get jealous that a new
baby is now coming and joining the
family but this helps that you know keep
them involved and you know keep them
excited about the new addition to the
family yeah I love that idea I don't
have one child but I could see it being
a huge point of stress for a lot of
parents who when they're having their
second how do I you know still involve
my first child in this process yeah how
many any stats or data or numbers that
talk about that that pain that parents
go through when in trying to bring a
second child into a family no I just
have like s my life experience and
that's basically the book is based on
real life it's based on my my three kids
I basically just put that into the book
and the experience that I went through
so I definitely think other parents can
relate to it I think it would make a
great media piece I think it would be a
great article on a lot of websites and
the newspapers and maybe lead to some
you know radio shows news shows and TV
spots it's not super difficult to put
together a lot of these media outlets
have email addresses that you can write
into to create a press release the thing
they're going to want to see there was
some kind of stocks and numbers right so
give me some data to show how parents
are suffering or stressed out or worried
about bringing you know a new second
child or third child into the family how
to integrate the current kids with it
okay all right and also I'm a single mom
there's not a lot of children's books
out there like what you know single mom
household so I also think that's like an
advantage to the book as well that you
know I went through all of this as being
like a single mom so yes and I could be
a whole other angle to write it could be
a second press release in second block
that I think it's hoping that I mean I
think as a parent I can relate to it I
can I'm already stressing out thinking
about OPI when I had a second child you
know how the how's it going to be
integrated my first into that I'm making
in part of the process so i would be a
customer for your book at barnes and
noble any online why on amazon no it's
great um so think of how many people can
easily relate to as its evening I'm if
you're trying to get press about it they
want to be with the show some statistics
and data to say
a this is a big deal like you're
attacking a big market this is why you
should care celebrate like your personal
story is amazing you speak really well I
love how all the kids have the the Y in
their name that's awesome so let me be
doing a little bit more research to find
out how parents are struggling with this
and why it's an important issue and then
that I would think that that would be
something that media would pick up on
pretty easily and have you in you know
again radio shows magazines newspapers
maybe TV spots and be being seen with an
expert to help families make this
transition okay so just get some facts
and statistics basically and try to put
that together and with my package and
submit that somehow yeah so what do I do
this is important right write a story
for them so look at their typical
stories don't just learn to trust me to
say hey waiting for baby why I write a
story as it to us up in the day with
publish so look at how they raise their
articles and try to write one like that
that includes you as the expert and all
the stats and figures in there and then
send it off all their email addresses
are online you can write to them let
them know you're available for
discussion I don't think you'll get
picked up great thank you I appreciate
the advice thanks i will definitely look
into doing back in the statistics and
everything cool awesome thanks for
calling in Tasha good luck all right
thank you so much once again if I Barnes
and Noble and Amazon so thanks waiting
for baby why I'm offense yeah guys
create a story getting sounds together
get some media it's so much better than
doing advertising because and people
write about you people pay attention to
the stories and not the ass will get
your story out there welcome back to the
Evan Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs I want to see you have a
lot of success of your company I also
want you to have success in your life
and a great way to merge both of those
is to do something nice so let me give
you a quick example I was talking to my
concierge at my building a couple weeks
ago when he mentioned to me that he
really loved playing this game when he
was a child called in
and you go out you buy these patents and
you buy and sell and trade them in the
game was out of print since the 1970s it
just came up in our casual conversation
when I could have left it at that but I
decided that I would go on ebay and go
check it out see if anybody has a copy
of this game and I found the guy who who
had a complete set in pretty good
condition and so i bought it i bought it
i brought it home got delivered and with
my four-year-old son you know we wrapped
it up pick some spider-man wrapping
paper and march downstairs to give the
concierge this gift and he opened it up
and was was speechless you know I
thought he was going to cry and he
started telling me a story about how
when he was younger he came from the
tiny remote village and he had no
internet had no TV and what he would do
is play this game with his dad and
seeing that game in printing right in
front of him it made his inmate of the
week and it made my week to you know
seeing him so happy he was going to go
call his dad and invite him over and
they're going to have a game together
and now one simple act is taking that
one element from his conversation with
me and acting on it really made an
impact on somebody's life and it did a
couple things you know it made him feel
great it made me feel great and it also
taught my son a valuable lesson and so I
encourage you to spend some time this
week just figure out one thing you do
nice or somebody and you know this game
cost me 30 40 bucks I don't have to cost
you anything just take some time out of
your day to help somebody else out and
everybody will feel better for I am time
for one last caller I have Callie on
hold Callie where are you from and how
can I help I'm in Laguna Beach
California I've recently changed career
paths and
this is going to sound really funny but
i live at artsy-fartsy community we have
the sawdust festival every summer and
I'm really trying to decide if I want to
go into you know an art form like
driftwood and that type of stuff okay so
what's holding you back well one I don't
know where you get driftwood from no I'm
just kidding you know I don't know I
think it's just two people actually buy
this stuff I go to stores and I see that
they sell you know handmade painting the
works of art that are just the dumbest
things that I've ever seen you can
probably find a walmart for five dollars
and they're getting a couple hundred
dollars from them you're working at a
company now you don't like it and you
want to start your own thing yes pretty
much okay no I'm super common um explore
you know like the best thing you can do
is explore just try it because once you
get into it you may find out that you
know what like this this is not what I
thought it was and you learn that
quickly or you may fall in love with it
and find an opportunity you want to keep
running with it so how long do you think
it takes to like them to get a business
off the ground running huh there's no
short answer for that but really it
should be something that you feel in
your heart is the right thing to do like
you should feel energized by this when
you are working if it's driftwood when
you're working with driftwood you should
you know get lost in it you should feel
like this is your calling you should
know in your heart that this is what you
were meant to do and if you get that
feeling then you have to keep going and
find a way and let me be part time right
you still keep your job you know you
don't like and that pays the bills until
your driftwood thing gets off the ground
or you may get into driftwood and it's
great for a couple months and you can
realize you know what like that's not
what I want to do I really want to get
into something else something totally
different I just don't wanna get a bunch
of driftwood in my garage no but start
small like start with one piece and then
another piece you don't need to go out
and buy thousand pieces of driftwood and
keep them in your garage well no I mean
you have to actually buy driftwood I was
wondering how to be able to find your
foot like I'm assuming that it sounds
funny but it's just wood drifting I get
that part but like how do you find your
foot well hey I mean I'm in Toronto we
don't have driftwood here but but but
that's part of your journey right like
there's going to be all of these
questions
we'll come out to on the course of you
building this business i'm going to get
into it there's going to be more
questions and more questions and your
journey is going to be discovering these
and Cena that you know that you haven't
fortis to keep going you really want to
pursue this or not if you are looking at
that and saying oh I've got to find your
food and it's such a pain in order to
get it and if all you see is the
problems with it and it's probably not
the right thing to go out there but if
this creates a sense of adventuring you
and you're excited by it and you're just
doing this naturally or you're seeking
us out you're looking for this
opportunity then it's worth continuing
on right like that could be you can turn
this into a business there are lots of
people who have done it if you have yeah
I know it even for stores and they've
got driftwood with Christmas lights and
I like I'm not trying to make fun of
them but it's got to be some of the
dumbest stuff I've ever seen that you
look at and go people are spending five
hundred dollars on some driftwood with
some tape and some Christmas lights I
can do that well so don't go into a
business just trying to make money right
like it's a it's a biggest mistake
people make you CEO I could do that and
so they see just as an opportunity money
you really do but if you're going into
it for a different reason give this is
your life's passion right like you want
to create and express yourself through
art then you'll have more success okay I
agree with that maybe I should try
something besides a dress with them if
you don't know what you want to do yet
just explore try lots of different stuff
Chargers will try one piece of driftwood
and see if you fall in love with it or
not you know if that's not it try
something else if you're an artistic
person try lots of different things get
your hand exposed a lot of different
areas until something feels right and
you get lost in it but you want to wake
up that next morning feeling I can't
wait to get started on my ex project
that's true i can i get started to get
some wood that doesn't make sense right
so it's not sustainable like if that's
three months in and you're still excited
by your tooth book project then keep
going with it and that could turn into a
business if it's hey this is a way to
make money on the side and I'm not that
excited about it you're not going to
have success so let your heart guide
your passion
I will all up my heart cuz what I love
it thank you so very much no problem
tally thanks for calling in and good
luck thank you thank you everybody it's
been another fantastic show Lorne
amazing as usual my producer and Josh
awesome job first show with me love it
super professional i'm on again in two
weeks everybody continue to build your
business continued to believe and i will
see you soon